my name is clay to me I'm from Forney
Texas my life kind of felt stale and I
wanted to pursue things that excited me
and so there were really no limits to
what kind of excitement I wanted to get
after I used to be a bank robber and I
served some time in prison and wha yes
sir
I was actually a very arrogant person I
thought I was it and a lot of that
arrogance manifested itself and in the
bank robbery
somehow I'm getting away with it so it
fed into my ego and there was a lot of
there was a lot of that going on but
there was also that that self-loathing
type of thing where I had just resigned
my life to failure at that point when my
son was born
it just had no appeal to me anymore
there was no joy there was no excitement
there was no thrill I was like you know
what I got a two month old baby who has
a daddy robbing banks and it's absurd I
finally called the police and I told him
I have some information regarding a bank
robbery and I said well I'd like to turn
myself in I guess I don't I don't know
what you want me to do he said well
we're yet I was at a hotel he said don't
leave we'll come and about 45 minutes
later the SWAT team came and took me to
jail and when I went to sleep and that
grimy jail cell with with no blankets
and it was just dirty I had I had I
experienced a piece that was unlike
anything that I had experienced before
that and when I woke up the next morning
it was it was my first day to wake up
sorry so the first day that I woke up in
jail was the first time that I'd ever
experienced freedom because all the
stuff that I had done to ruin my life
was officially behind me and that was to
start up something new when you're in
that environment where you have no
responsibilities and you can just work
on yourself then you can really focus on
what needs to change and by the time I
got out you know a little over three
years later I hit the ground running I
had a job within 48 hours I was working
in the oil fields out in West Texas I
was in a truck just a pickup truck you
know driving around all day delivering
parts to our rigs I like to listen to
talk radio flipping through the station
even maybe step number two is the dead
snow moment when just by chance I heard
Dave's voice answering a phone call and
you know the typical better than I
deserve type of thing and it just
sounded like a positive show and to me
everything that Dave said was just
completely logical I don't really have a
lot of debt and I started thinking well
I have you know the restitution from
robbing the banks I have to pay that
back
I guess that's debt I started kind of
mentally going through the debts that I
had and next thing you know I do owe a
lot of money oh oh like 40-something
thousand dollars worth of debt and from
that point forward you know it was over
time over time over time and it was all
that money was just going to debt to
debt and getting rid of it and getting
rid of it to me debt is just a different
type of prison the last thing I paid off
was the restitution that was actually
just Friday I went wow yeah the last
little chunk of that was
down in the courthouse and downtown
dallas at the federal building down
there this is the place where I was
arraigned where I was sentenced and also
where I paid off the last of my
restitution took them their money order
and it was that was it
my criminal stuff was behind me and
there was nothing that attached my
future to my past a portion of the past
that really needs to be left in the past
is over Oh buddy you have no idea how
bad I mean when that when I left the
14th floor there and and I don't want to
exaggerate but to say that it's the same
as the day that I got out of prison is
how I felt when I got in the button and
I pushed one on the elevator to get out
of that place and I was done that was it
and my past was in the past but I didn't
know anybody because the end of it it's
a big deal for my two boys to understand
that debt is a bad thing and what's the
easiest toilet you have good only
grocery to teach him how to manage his
money and how to be responsible because
my view on money was was horrible and I
didn't know anything about how to manage
finances properly until I started
listening to to the show count it down
let's hear a great debt free scream
three two one I'm dead
and absolutely awesome absolutely
awesome